hello and welcome to this episode of the
apig accelerator Series in this video
you'll see how to improve an api's
performance by leveraging aags built in
caching policies to improve response
times lower costs or decrease load on
your backend Services while still being
able to scale let's take a high Lev look
at how this works with a cash response
policy say you have appg in front of the
API and a request comes in if the
response from the API is not in the cash
the request will be forwarded to the
Target back
end once a response is received it is
placed into the cache using the key of
your choosing and forwarded to the API
client on subsequent requests if the
cash lookup
succeeds the response is sent
immediately to the API client without
placing additional load on the target
back
end now that you've seen the high level
overview let's see how to deploy the ex
accelerator in order to run this sample
you need to have an apx instance
provisioned with access configured for
external traffic and as a user you'll
need to have access to deploy the API
proxies this can be granted using either
the API admin or or admin roles and
lastly to deploy the sample you'll need
the command line tool shown
here good news is that if you're using
Google Cloud shell these are already
installed this sample can be
demonstrated using either the cloud
shell quick start tutorial or following
the setup
instructions in this video we'll use the
cloudshell quick
start click open in Google cloudshell to
open the cloudshell
environment once the environment is
loaded let's follow the instructions
provided in the
tutorial first you will want to make
sure that you log in using the right
account then we'll navigate naate to the
right
folder and then open the EnV Dosh
file there we're going to set the
environment variables to reference your
epig project the target environment and
the external host
name next run the included script to
deploy the sample to your appg instance
this will take about a minute to
complete once it completes you'll see a
message with the API proxy URL
now to test the effect of caching we'll
run a curl command that outputs the
total response
time take note of the total time from
the first
request we'll run the same request a
subsequent time this time the request
will be served from cash as can be seen
by the lower response time almost 10x
faster in my
instance all right now that you've seen
this policy in action let's take a look
at how this is conf configured in apy in
a new tab open the API management UI you
can navigate to it from the Google Cloud
console by searching for apig in the
search
bar in the API proxies page you should
see the basic caching proxy select the
proxy and go to the develop
tab you'll see several policies but the
one you're interested in right now is
the response cach policy this is where
you configure the cash key to use
how long the item should remain in the
cach and conditions for which You Should
Skip looking up an item from the cach or
placing an item into the
cache when you're done with this sample
you can switch back to the cloudshell
editor to provide us feedback and to use
the cleanup script to delete the
configuration that was deployed to your
apig
instance thanks for watching I hope this
content was useful to you if you have
not signed up for apig yet use this link
if you have any questions please visit
the apog community and subscribe to our
channel to see more videos in the apog
accelerator series